bonsoir à tous on ne présente comme
journaliste reporter mais si vous me
demandez quel est mon métier je peux
tout aussi bien vous dire que je vis la
vie d'autrui par procuration si si je
vous assure comment vous appelez une
personne qui s'invite dans votre maison
sur votre lieu de travail dans votre
voiture et même là où vous partez en
vacances
imaginez un peu cette personne vous suit
partout vous filme et en plus vous posez
des tas de questions et ce pendant des
heures des jours des semaines ou encore
des mois épuisants dans une des rues
mais entendons nous voulons avait donné
l'autorisation parce que vous y aviez
intérêt mais je vais vous dire en quoi
ce travail est nécessaire pourquoi
raconter ses histoires du quotidien vos
histoires est essentiel et comment la
presse est un formidable contre-pouvoir
mesdames et messieurs
si je me suis je si je me suis rendu
compte d'une chose c'est qu'il n'ya pas
trente mille façons de faire du
journalisme ou de réinventer le
journalisme de demain l'essence même de
ce métier c'est de se confronter à
l'épreuve du terrain c'est une recette
vieille comme le monde et qui
fonctionnera toujours je le pense
on peut toujours discuter de la forme
mais sur le fond le genre du reportage
est celui qui permet le mieux de toucher
du doigt une certaine réalité en faisant
remonter l'information depuis sa source
pour ce faire le reporter dispose de
formidables outils
sa curiosité et ses cinq sens pour
pouvoir s'adapter à toutes les
situations
cela tient en une phrase une presse qui
promènent librement ses chaussures des
tapis broder des ministères aux
bas-fonds des quartiers les plus
sordides
contribuer à changer notre société
mais laissez moi vous raconter
un jour que je sortais de chez moi
parlant beau matin je me suis retrouvé
comme projeté avec mon coéquipier
caméraman non loin de la ville du cap à
la veille des élections sud africaine on
atterrit dans un township vous savez
c'est énorme ghetto parmi les plus
dangereux au monde dans lesquels végète
les populations noires donc pauvres de
ce pays
sur le macadam une tâche de sont encore
fraîches
la nuit précédente un jeune homme avait
été abattu quelques mètres plus loin
deux enfants jouant à se tirer dessus
avec des pistolets en plastique le décor
était planté
notre contact sur place nous emmène
quelques kilomètres plus loin à flanc de
colline pour ne montrer le nouvel exode
des habitants des bidonvilles sur des
dizaines d'hectares d'un vignoble qui
produisait les meilleurs crus d'afrique
du sud il avait installé des centaines
d'abris en tôle
divenah avec leur famille sans eau
courante ni électricité
parce qu'ils avaient décidé d'occuper
ses terres appartenant à des fermiers
blancs
les blancs une minorité qui continue de
posséder l'immense majorité des
richesses et des ressources économiques
de ce pays
près de trente ans après la fin de la
ségrégation
avec les occupants on a partagé des
tranches de vie on a essayé de
comprendre pourquoi et comment il en
était arrivé là e naturellement ce ont
exprimé leurs revendications
face à notre caméra
mais les choses se sont corsées par la
suite aucun propriétaire terrien ne
voulait témoigner à la télévision or il
nous fallait absolument leur point de
vue pour sortir quelque chose
d'équilibré sur un sujet aussi polémique
ou alors c'était un échec
on a fait du porte à porte passons de
l'un à l'autre de leur immense vignoble
c'était une véritable galère mais dans
les dernières heures qu'il nous restait
avant de quitter la région on est tombé
sur cette femme pour le moins bavarde vu
le contexte on a fait quelque chose
d'exceptionnel
on l'a interviewé en caméra cachée et
c'est précisément là carrément très son
vrai visage
elle a eu cette phrase dont je me
rappellerai toujours
au temps de l'apartheid c'était mieux
avec mon coéquipier on a monté le
reportage la nuit même en prenant soin
de rendre la dame anonyme avant de
sauter dans l'avion vers de nouvelles
aventures
sur le fil
que c'est beau de pouvoir accomplir sa
mission librement dans un contexte
difficile où un environnement parfois
hostile
et pourtant
mesdames et messieurs dans un monde
idéal chaque reporter serez libre de
traiter n'importe quel sujet sur
n'importe quel territoire pour le porter
à la connaissance du public sans être
entravé dans son travail sans finir
incarcéré captifs ou bien
le journalisme mais pas un crime
pourtant trop d'entre nous on paie le
prix fort
pourtant des textes fondamentaux de
droit international tels que ceux
rattachés à la charte des nations unies
ou encore à la charte africaine des
droits de l'homme et des peuples protège
le libre exercice en temps de conflit
comme en temps de paix
à titre personnel je pourrais vous
raconter
la fois où je me suis retrouvé cuisiner
dans les locaux des services de
renseignements dans un pays
je dois encore vous parler de la foi ou
à deux jours de sa diffusion une chaîne
a déprogrammé une enquête documentaire
que nous avions réalisé pendant de longs
mois pour ne pas entacher la réputation
et les intérêts financiers de puissantes
entreprises dont nous révélions les
arnaques
je pourrais enfin vous raconter le jour
où un ministre africain dont je tairai
le nom a tenté de me remettre des
millions alors que je m'entretenais avec
lui dans son bureau
on voulait savoir qui c'est
ok préparez vous si vous voulez des
scoops on s'attend à la sortie l'an
sérieusement corrompre un journaliste
c'est déjà lui enlever sa raison d'être
mais en plus c'est court circuitait ce
vecteur essentiel dans la transmission
de l'information et du savoir la
pratique est bien trop récurrente dans
nos pays une certaine presse est inféodé
de manière flagrante au pouvoir
alors médias chaînes journaux
donnons aux journalistes chaque jour sur
le terrain au plus près de l'action les
moyens d'exercer décemment il en va de
la bonne santé de nos systèmes et de nos
sociétés
vous savez lorsque enfant je rêvais
d'être comme ses reporters du bout du
monde que je voyais à la télévision
j'étais loin d'imaginer tout ça j'étais
loin de me rendre compte des sacrifices
personnels auxquels il fallait qu'on
s'en tire tout laisser en plan du jour
au lendemain se jeter dans les bras de
l'inconnu et parfois prendre des risques
insensés
vite vite remplir les éditions
enfin dans l' aventure de l'adrénaline
de quoi étancher sa soif de connaissance
et nourrir cet insatiable boulimie pour
les expériences humaines
je voulais d'y vivre par procuration
même si parfois c'est violent et je
voudrais ce jour avoir une pensée pour
tous mes contraire un trend
arbitrairement privé de liberté sur le
continent et spécialement à olivier
dubois mon pote enlevé par les
djihadistes au mali depuis le mois
d'avril
mais vous savez en tant que journaliste
et reporter nous avons une chance inouïe
être des témoins privilégiés de notre
époque raconter les évolutions de nos
sociétés
parler des injustices relaté les
parcours individuels collectifs mettre
en lumière des faits tout ceci
c'est participer à ce que vous vous ou
vous puissiez prendre conscience
réfléchir et agir chacun votre échelle
je dis humblement
mais c'est la haute idée que je me fais
de ce métier
je veux continuer de croire qu'on étend
ses traits d'union entre les gens nous
et par extension le reportage puissions
avoir un impact concret peser
même si dans notre monde dominé par les
réseaux sociaux la brièveté et
l'instantanéité des messages une
information est rapidement chassé par
une autre ou alors vidé de sa substance
j'étais à ce moment-là correspondant
pour une chaîne internationale au mali
voisin pays
qui fait depuis des années face à une
crise multidimensionnelle et notamment
sécuritaires
à bamako des femmes et des enfants aux
majorités afflué depuis le centre du
pays dont les camps de déplacés déjà
plein à craquer
ces civils qui je le rappelle sont
toujours les premières victimes des
conflits fuyaient les violences
meurtrières entre les communautés pour
l'accès aux ressources qui les attaquent
djihadistes
la fin se lisait dans les yeux de ces
femmes et de ces enfants obligés de
fouiller les décharges publiques pour
espérer survivre parce que l'aide
alimentaire n'était pas suffisante pour
tous
comme d'habitude nous sommes immergés
dans leur quotidien pour raconter leur
histoire
après la diffusion de ce reportage j'ai
reçu de nombreux messages provenant de
pays d'afrique et de france
des gens avaient été touchés il voulait
faire des dons aux organisations
humanitaires qui prenait en charge ces
réfugiés et ils l'ont fait par centaines
de milliers de francs cfa une goutte
d'eau certainement mais une solidarité
aussi spontanée qu'inattendue qui m'a
rendu fier de faire ce métier
en conclusion je voudrais vous dire ceci
il existe plusieurs manières de faire du
journalisme
de nombreux supports plusieurs genres
multitude de formats différentes lignes
éditoriales et une infinité de sujets à
traiter
mais l'information vérifiée mise en
forme et diffusée est une ressource
primordiale pour tous
alors dans le reportage continuons
d'enfoncer les portes pour montrer ce
qu'on ne voit pas
continuons d'escalader les barrières
pour raconter ce qui se passe au delà
n'arrêtons pas d'affaiblir ce devoir qui
offre à chacun d'entre nous les clés de
compréhension de notre monde
parce qu'une presse qui promènent
librement ses chaussures des tapis
broder des ministères aux bas-fonds des
quartiers les plus sordides
contribuer à changer notre société
et vu comment agissez-vous pour changer
notre société
[Applaudissements]